MISSION IS.
MARK?
>> Mark: THANKS, JONATHAN.
JUAN HERNANDEZ IS A FORMER
ADVISOR TO THE MEXICAN PRESIDENT
AND HE JOINS US NOW.
IN WHAT SENSE ARE THESE PEOPLE
IN THE CARAVAN ASYLUM-SEEKERS?
>> I MET WITH MANY OF THEM.
I MET WITH THE 7200 CARAVAN IN
THE STATE THAT I NOW WORK WITH
UNDER THE GOVERNOR, SPECIFICALLY
UNDER THE GOVERNOR, SPECIFICALLW
UNDER THE GOVERNOR, SPECIFICALLR
UNDER THE GOVERNOR, SPECIFICALLI
UNDER THE GOVERNOR, SPECIFICALLG
UNDER THE GOVERNOR, SPECIFICALLW
UNDER THE GOVERNOR, SPECIFICALLT
UNDER THE GOVERNOR, SPECIFICALLH
IMMIGRANTS.
MOSTLY MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS LIVING
IN THE UNITED STATES.
BUT ALSO, IT WAS MY DUTY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE TREAT IT IN A
HUMANITARIAN WAY, THESE 7,200.
I TELL YOU, YOU SIT DOWN WITH
THEM FOR A MINUTE AND YOU ARE IN
TEARS.
THESE ARE CHILDREN, THESE ARE
WOMEN.
LET ME FINISH -- THESE ARE
PEOPLE LOOKING FOR A BETTER WAY
OF LIFE LIKE YOUR FAMILY AND MY
FAMILY DID MANY YEARS AGO COMING
TO THE UNITED STATES.
>> Mark: I DIDN'T COME AS AN
ASYLUM'S ACRE, BUT IF I WAS AND
ASYLUM-SEEKERS
, THIS CARAVAN HAS MARCHED
ACROSS TWO NATIONAL FRONTIERS.
IT MARCHED INTO GUATEMALA
ILLEGALLY AND THEN IT MARCHED
INTO MEXICO ILLEGALLY.
IF YOU ARE AN ASYLUM-SEEKER, I
AM SUPPOSED TO SEEK ASYLUM IN
THE FIRST SAFE COUNTRY I COME
TO?
>> MY FRIEND, WE ALL KNOW THE
UNITED STATES IS TODAY THE MOST
POWERFUL NATION IN THE WORLD.
IT IS THEIR DREAM OF MANY, MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST TRYING TO
GET OUT OF DIRE POVERTY,
VIOLENCE, TO BE ABLE TO REACH
THE UNITED STATES AND TO BE A
BLESSING, AS THEY ARE THE
IMMIGRANTS TO THIS NATION.
THAT'S THE DREAM.
THEY ARE COMING TO THE
UNITED STATES, AND THEY ARE
SEEKING ASYLUM.
THEY ARE NOT INNOVATING.
IT'S SUCH A SMALL NUMBER.
>> Mark: WAIT A MINUTE -- YOU
ARE NOW SAYING THAT A DREAM IS A
BASIS FOR ASYLUM.
I MIGHT HAVE A DREAM --
>> DEFINITELY.
>> Mark: I MIGHT HAVE A DREAM
TO LIVE IN BARBRA STREISAND
HOUSE, DOESN'T MEAN I HAVE A
RIGHT TO MOVE INTO HER GUEST
BEDROOM.
>> IF YOU ARE A BLOCK AWAY FROM
HER HOME AND YOU ARE BEING
ATTACKED AND BEING AND YOUR
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY H
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY V
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY E
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY I
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY S
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY T
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY O
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY J
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY I
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY N
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY A
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY G
CHILDREN, THE ONLY CHANCE THEY N
AND YOU CAN'T EVEN FEED THEM,
YOU WOULD BE KNOCKING ON THAT
MOVIE STARS, SAYING, IS THERE
SOME WAY THAT I CAN BE HERE IN
YOUR HOME AND WORK FOR YOU?
>> Mark: SHE STILL WOULDN'T
LET ME END.
YOU KNOW THAT.
>> SHE WOULD.
SHE WOULD.
>> Mark: HERE'S THE THING, YOU
TALK ABOUT ALL THE CHILDREN,
THERE ARE WOMEN BEING RAPED,
THESE ARE OVERWHELMINGLY YOUNG
MEN.
WHAT KIND OF ASYLUM-SEEKERS
LEAVE THE OLD AND THE SICK, AND
THE KIDS, AND THE WOMEN FOLK
BACK IN GUATEMALA, OR WHEREVER,
AND IT'S JUST THE YOUNG MEN WHO
COME ACROSS THE FRONTIER?
IT'S OVERWHELMINGLY YOUNG MEN.
>> YES, PROBABLY ABOUT 75% TO
80% ARE YOUNG MEN, YOU ARE
RIGHT.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO WANT TO DO
BETTER FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEY ARE LEAVING DESPERATELY.
THEY SEE NO WAY THAT THEY CAN BE
ABLE TO SURVIVE IN SOME OF THE
PLACES WHERE THEY COME FROM.
>> Mark: NO, NO, NO.
EVERYONE WITH A DREAM, THERE ARE
7 BILLION PEOPLE ON THE PLANET
AND AS YOU SAY, AMERICA IS THE
MOST POWERFUL, WEALTHIEST, ALL
THE REST OF IT.
THE FACT THAT THAT GIVES
6.5 BILLION PEOPLE THE RIGHT TO
MOVE TO THE UNITED STATES?
>> IT'S NOT THAT IT IS A
RIGHT -- ALTHOUGH MANY WOULD
CLAIM THAT IT IS A HUMAN RIGHT
THAT IF YOU ARE IN A DIRE
SITUATION, YOU ARE GOING TO TRY,
EVEN IF YOU HAVE TO BREAK SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE RULES.
THEY HAVE NOT COMMITTED CRIMES.
THEY ARE JUST SEEKING ASYLUM.
>> Mark: YOU ARE NOW START OF
THE STATE GOVERNMENT IN MEXICO.
>> YES, SIR.
PROBABLY.
>> Mark: WHAT IS WRONG WITH
YOUR ESTATE IF THEY JUST WANT A
BETTER LIFE?
WHY CAN'T THEY MOVE TO YOUR
STATE?
YOUR ESTATE IS BETTER THAN
HONDURAS, WHEREVER THEY COME
FROM.
>> YES, IT IS.
THE DREAM FOR THEM IS THE
UNITED STATES.
THERE IS A WONDERFUL ARTICLE BY
A PRIEST FROM HONDURAS AND HE
CALLED AT THE BOIL OVER.
I SUGGEST MANY OF YOUR VIEWERS
READ IT.
I THINK IT CAME OUT IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THE
TRANSLATION.
HE SAID THESE ARE PEOPLE, THEY
ARE NOT ORGANIZED, THEY WEREN'T
PAID BY EVERYONE.
DOZENS WERE GOING TO DESPERATELY
LEAVE THE COUNTRY AND IT JUST
BOILED OVER.
IT LITERALLY THOUSANDS SAID WE
CAN TAKE IT NO LONGER, WE MUST
SEEK A BETTER LIFE.
IT IS HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
TODAY THERE ARE TWO AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE GOING FROM ONE
COUNTRY TO ANOTHER TRYING TO
FIND A BETTER LIFE.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT.
WE MUST BE A COUNTRY OF LAWS --
MEXICO AND THE UNITED STATES --
AND PEOPLE ARE BEING TESTED.
OTHER NATIONS HAVE NOT PASSED
THE TEST.
WE NEED TO PASS THIS TEST OF
BEING HUMANITARIAN AND DECENCY
TO THESE PEOPLE.
>> Mark: WHY IS IT IN THE
INTEREST OF THESE OTHER
COUNTRIES FOR ALL OF THEIR MOST
TALENTED PEOPLE TO MOVE TO THE
UNITED STATES OR WESTERN EUROPE?
WHY IS IT IN THE INTEREST OF
GUATEMALA OR ANYWHERE ELSE TO BE
DENUDED OF ITS MOST TALENTED
PEOPLE?
>> WELL, SURE, IT'S MOSTLY
ECONOMIC.
IN THE UNITED STATES -- AND I'M
SURE YOU DO -- READ THE
STATISTICS, THE UNITED STATES IS
GROWING AT LESS THAN 1%.
THE UNITED STATES NEEDS ABOUT
350,000 NEW PEOPLE EVERY YEAR.
THESE 10,000 ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
I MET THEM --
>> Mark: THEY MAY BE GOOD
PEOPLE --
>> THEY ARE DOING GREAT,
FINANCIALLY, BUT THERE DREAM IS
TO COME TO THE UNITED STATES.
>> Mark: THERE ARE PLENTY OF
GOOD PEOPLE.
IF YOU GO TO THESE AIRPORTS, YOU
GET YOUR MAIL ORDER ON A
MACHINE.
NOBODY NEEDS PEOPLE ANYMORE,